with that said here's this
question open up your Bible if you can
if you can bring it up or you want to
just read it you want to have the Bible
you go I am showing it live now on
screen oh there you go all right John
167 open it up because here's the
objection if I understood your objection
I'm going to repeat it but first let me
objection so this is going to benefit
All Of You John
167 all
right so here's the question
nevertheless I tell you the truth it is
to your advantage that I go for if I do
not go away the helper will not come to
you but if I depart I will send him to
you so the objection goes like this
here's the
objection how can the comforter be or
the helper be the Holy Spirit when Jesus
says I must go for him to come because
if it's the Holy Spirit the Holy Spirit
was already there the spirit was already
there when Jesus is on Earth he was
there before Jesus came to the Earth but
whoever this helper is he wasn't there
and would only come after Jesus left
so how can it be the Holy Spirit do you
guys understand the objection so I can
answer it before I move
on let me just remember there's a 16c
day now as they do it I want you to line
up Luke 1 Luke
1:15
comma right and then you're going to do
comma and then you're going to do 67
semicolon not comma you got to do
semicolon now and then
two 25 to 35 okay now so you guys
understand it right so the Holy Spirit
was already there before Jesus came
while Jesus came but whoever this helper
is he wasn't there and would only come
later well are they right was the Holy
Spirit already there yeah let's read it
Luke 1:15 now open it up and read for us
brother Luke 1:15 for he will be great
in the sight of the Lord and shall drink
neither wine nor strong drink he will
also be filled with the Holy Spirit even
from his mother's womb now this is John
the Baptist yes this is long before
Jesus started his ministry John the
Baptist would be filled with the spirit
in his mother's room so the Holy Spirit
was there filling John who else did the
Holy Spirit fill what's the next
verse and it happened when Elizabeth
heard the greeting of Mary that the B
baby leaped in her womb and Elizabeth
was filled with the Holy Spirit okay so
now his mother is filled the Holy Spirit
and this is even before Jesus is born
Mary the Blessed Mother just conceived
Jesus okay what about John's father Luke
167 now his father Zechariah was filled
with the Holy Spirit and prophesied
saying so John's parents and John while
still in the womb all filled with the
Holy Spirit even for the Blessed Virgin
conceived Jesus and
during Jesus's conception now when Jesus
is born were there others who were
filled and guided by the spirit yeah
Simeon Luke 2 25-35 specifically Luke 2
25-28 read and behold there was a man in
Jerusalem whose name was Simeon and his
man uh and this man was just The Devout
just and devout waiting for the
consolation of Israel and the Holy
Spirit was upon him so he had the Holy
Spirit too right yes sir and Jesus had
just been born and they're going to
present him in the temple so keep going
and it had been revealed to him by the
holy spirit that he would not see death
before he had seen the Lord's Christ so
he came by the spirit into the temple
and when the parents brought the Child
Jesus to do for him according to the
custom of the law he took him up in his
arms and blessed God and said
now you can stop there you got it right
yes sir three times the holy spirit is
mentioned reference to Simeon so that
was the Holy Spirit already active and
on the earth before enduring and after
Jesus's conception and birth yes yes
what about in the Old Testament let's go
some some Old Testament examples are you
ready yes sir okay go up put on Genesis
4138 Let's Line them up I'm not going to
give you all of them but some of them
Genesis
4138 okay 38 and now
semicolon Exodus
semicolon okay now put I'm saying
numbers
24:2
semicolon
Deuteronomy
34:9 34:9
semicolon 1st Samuel
10:6 comma comma 9
to11 semicolon oh by the way put judges
634 I forgot that one judge no it's okay
step yeah we judge at
634 and then I'll give you a few more
634 and then you do Psalm
5111 Psalm not FMS with Palms you sound
like okay
semicolon
143 yeah and then
semicolon and then final one because
there's too many Micah 38 m i c k m i c
ah okay now go ahead now read it for us
is the holy spirit there was he there in
the and the Old Testament indwelling
empowering working through the prophets
read
Genesis 41:38 and Pharaoh said to the
servants can we find such a one in this
a man in whom is the spirit of God now
that's Joseph so Joseph had the Holy
Spirit right yep keep
going Exodus 31:3 and I have filled him
with the spirit of God in wisdom in
understanding in knowledge and in all
manners of worksmanship that's Basia so
the holy spirit filled him to empower
him to construct the Tabernacle okay
go numbers 242 and balam raised his eyes
and saw Israel encamped according to
their tribes and the spirit of God Came
Upon him side note balam or balam was
the false prophet a sorcerer who was
into Witchcraft and sorcery whom God
condemned to death and yet even here the
Holy Spirit inspired him so I want you
to learn something before we move on the
holy spirit is so Almighty and glorious
and Majestic he can even cause and
Inspire false teachers to speak truth
because balum balam a false prophet a
sorcerer who was into sorcery witchcraft
who enticed Israel to worship ba and
commit orgies was put to death by orders
of God but before he did that the Holy
Spirit came upon him and compelled him
to prophesy the truth about Israel and
the future about Israel who did that the
spirit of God so the holy spirit is so
Majestic and glorious and Almighty he
can even have false teachers speak truth
so go ahead
amen Deuteronomy 349 now Joshua the son
of Na was full of the spirit of wisdom
Spirit wisdom even though they put lower
case it's meaning it's the Holy Spirit
who gave them wisdom to be able to lead
Israel
amen keep
going 1st Samuel 10:6 then the spirit of
the Lord will come upon you and you will
prophesy with them and be turned into
another man this is talking about Saul
Samuel told Saul the holy spirit will
come and make you a new creation cause
you to be born again a new creation here
is being born again being made new a new
creation already in the Old Testament
the spirit of the Lord will come on you
Saul and he'll make you a new man a new
creature cause you to be born from above
so that you can then be empowered by the
spirit as long as you don't resist him
to rule in accord with God's will but
sadly he rebelled and the spirit left
him and an evil spirit possessed him now
what happened to him in 9-1 same chapter
1 Samuel 10 99-1 9-1 so it was when he
had turned his back to go from Samuel
that God gave him another heart and all
those signs came to pass that day when
they came there to the hill there was a
group of prophets to meet him then the
spirit of God Came Upon him and he
prophesied among them now notice the
sign before you go notice the sign that
Saul had become a new creation a new man
transformed and now he was filled with
the Holy Spirit he started
prophesying a sign that now the spirit
had come upon him and changed his nature
to be able to rule in accord to God's
will so finish
it and it happened when all who knew him
formally saw that he indeed prophesied
among the prophets that the people said
to one another what is this that he has
come upon the son of Kish is Saul also
among the prophets so there you go now
the rest read the rest so we can then
answer your
question David this is this is Gideon
I'm sorry judges 634 Gideon 634 but the
spirit of the Lord Came Upon Gideon then
he blew the trumpet and the the ab
isites gathered behind him so again the
holy spirit is active in the Old
Testament you see it he fills people he
indwells people he empowers people he
transforms people so he's was there in
the Old Testament he was there during
the time of Christ what about D what
does David say because he committed
adultery this is a passage that many use
to show you can be cut off from
salvation and lose salvation and be
rejected by the spirit and up dying
because notice what David says he has
committed adultery and murder and he's
afraid then now he be cut off and die so
he says do not cast me away from your
presence and do not take your Holy
Spirit from me so David's afraid because
of my sin I deserve that you cut me off
from your presence take away the Holy
Spirit of life and hand me over to death
but please don't do that have mercy on
me so even David knew he needed the Holy
Spirit to be preserved and empowered to
live a life pleasing to the Lord because
without the Holy Spirit he would die and
wither amen so what what does Psalm
143:10 say teach me to do your will for
you are my God
your spirit is good Lead Me In the Land
of UPR righteousness so who empowers him
to leads him in the righteous path the
spirit of God who is good right yep okay
the final ones go ahead M but truly I am
full of Power by the spirit of the Lord
and of justice and might to declare to
Jacob his transgressions and to Israel
his sin so there you go now did everyone
see that the Holy Spirit has been active
from the time of creation and was active
and present even during the time of
Jesus's virginal conception and birth so
the Holy Spirit was there everyone saw
that y I know you saw so I want to let
give them a chance so if you saw that
then now we have to explain what Jesus
meant in John
16:7 that he must go for the helper to
come if the helper's the Holy Spirit why
would Jesus need to go for the spirit to
come because the spirit was already
there well well not let me give you the
answer now go back up let's get look at
the
answer okay now put in John 14 I'm going
to show you the answer from our Lord
John 1416 to1
17 and then
semicolon 1
32-33
semicolon 738
to39 okay now let me show you Jesus
actually says the helper is there
already he already said that he already
said the helper who's the spirit truth
he's already here so why did you say I
must go for him to come now read this
for me now we're going to see the
answer and I'll pray the father and he
will give you another helper that he may
abide with you forever the spirit of
Truth whom the world cannot receive
because it neither sees him nor knows
him but you know him for he dwells with
you and will be in you so now did you C
it that Jesus is saying the helper is
here he's right here with you and you
know he's with you because he's working
through
me but then what will happen he will
then be in
you right now he's with you because he's
in me working through me but then he'll
be in you when will he be in you when I
leave do you catch
it well I'm waiting for you Adam did you
catch it yes yes and so Jesus says you
disciples know who he is he's here with
you where where is he he's in me working
through me and him and I with the father
are doing the Miracles so the Miracles
are showing you he's here with me but
then he'll be in you when will he be in
you when I leave why is it he'll only be
in them working through them when Jesus
leaves you can now read John 13233 the
next
passages read that for me and John bore
witness saying I saw the Spirit
descending from heaven like a dove and
he remained upon Him Christ I did not
know him but he who sent me to baptize
with water said to me upon whom you see
the spirit descending and remaining on
him this is he who baptized with the
Holy Spirit now you see when the Holy
Spirit came down visibly and John saw
the Holy Spirit appear visibly as a dove
it said it came down and remained on
Jesus that's the answer from the time
Jesus began his ministry the spirit
remained on Jesus and now would work
through Jesus's physical body to bring
people to Christ so he remained on him
from that moment on then when Jesus was
glorified then the Spirit came into the
disciples Now read John 7
3839 yes sir and there's your answer
he who believes in me as the scripture
has said out of his heart will flow
rivers of Living Water but this he spoke
concerning the spirit whom those
believing in him would receive for the
Holy Spirit was not yet given because
Jesus was not yet glorified did you get
your answer absolutely sir so why did
Jesus say I must go for the spirit to
come because as long long as I'm on
Earth the spirit will be with me in me
in all his fullness working through me
and he'll remain with me until I'm
glorified and after I'm glorified then
he will be given to all of you who
believe
amen so did you get the answer now
absolutely all right we're done brother
so that's it I hope you got it